this past weekend we saw a really
horrifying
tragedy happen in chicago there was a
man and his significant other this woman
were
driving through the humboldt park
neighborhood of chicago with a puerto
rican flag
when something happened where they got
ambushed they were dragged or fell out
of the car
and they were well the man was executed
the woman was left for dead but is in
critical condition it's a horrifying
story it's a horrifying story about
chicago now
do you expect a story like that to make
the mainstream media usually it doesn't
but there is an interesting story that
emerged from it a founder of a democrat
pac political action committee responded
to ann coulter when she tweeted about
this not appearing in the news by saying
it was a white guy with a confederate
flag
so who cares and then realizing
that he was wrong said well i was just
saying that if it was a white guy i'd
have been agnostic on it
which is insane i mean it's absolutely
insane like
who in their right mind is going to be
like that was a good thing or or at
least be
not like no no it's wrong to kill people
violence is bad war is bad it's all bad
we don't like it
we're when it comes to international
conflict and fights
we regret that we even have to defend
ourselves
when when a police officer when someone
in the military or even a regular
homeowner is forced to defend themselves
it's a traumatic experience
taking someone's life yet we have people
right now on social media gloating and
laughing about it
there's another event that happened too
especially if you've been following my
my channels you have seen this
a pride event in seattle is going to be
charging white people reparations to
attend
so this is all in line with the insanity
that is
i should say the application of critical
race theory
and we're hearing from so many people on
the left just outright lying saying
schools aren't teaching this theory and
things like that but they are
and this is the kind of stuff that it
leads to and it's also a big problem of
social media so we're going to talk
about this we're talking about a lot of
things
and we are being joined by a political
commentator and legal
expert i'll just call you there you go
ron coleman
legal expert yeah boy you know that's
vague
certainly in the room i must be the
biggest legal expert yes
i'm allowed to say it because i'm
certainly not i mean you're a lawyer for
what 30-something years or so you said
30-something years yeah and for someone
who's only 40 years old
yeah that's right ian's actually online
prodigy
you're 10 you're in the you know pass
the bar very early
ask anyone who knew me they will stand
up and agree that i was
quite the advocate you specialize in
first amendment law or
what is your specialty well that's
that's really where i have found myself
now i mean
i'm i'm a civil or commercial litigator
and most of my career has been
representing parties in involved in
court battles that are not criminal law
and that covered a very very wide range
of topics but one of the things that i
was interested in early in my career was
trademark
law which is something that appealed to
me maybe my interesting sensibility
all kinds of things i got more involved
more involved in trademarks
and when the internet hit i got
increasingly involved
in the use of intellectual property law
as a way of
eliminating competition on the on the
internet by claiming trademark
infringement as a way to
shut people up or copyright infringement
as a way of shutting people up
i got more and more involved with first
amendment law
also as an orthodox jew i was frequently
called upon in my community
to help out on religious liberties
issues
so the first amendment became more and
more of a friend
and then when i represented the slants
in their challenge to the lanamax
prohibition
on the registration of trademarks that
disparaged
people and we won that in the united
states supreme court i then was able to
combine
my interest in trademark law and first
amendment law
and become known as more of a first
amendment lawyer
and now i'm partners with army dylan
who's been doing
all this religious liberties and free
speech stuff for all these years
and my life is essentially perfect so we
can we can talk a lot about section 230
which uh i've had a lot of arguments
about it be interesting to hear your
thoughts as well
it will so we'll get in all that stuff
as well so uh would it be in we got
lydia pressing on the button i am here
in the corner
pushing buttons i'm excited for this
evening for this voice of knowledge she
does know how to push but you do yes
it's true
no she was killing me last night on on
twitter
even this afternoon right right up to
them oh yeah you got to keep it going
before we get started my friends we got
an amazing sponsor
we got biotrust in the description below
you will see the link
eatrightandfeelwell.com it's very easy
to remember right eatright
and feelwell.com you get 51 percent off
keto elevate from biotrust it is medium
chain triglyceride uh what does that
mean
it means uh it's good energy it's the
good fats it's the fats you want
if you're trying to do the keto diet you
don't want to be eating well obviously
you don't need a lot of sugar you eat a
lot of carbs you want to get good fats
so this stuff is like powder
you mix it right into your drinks or
your smoothies whatever ian's always
dumping it in his coffee and so you're
making my mouth water thank you
and uh it's great it's great it adds
like a good creaminess to to your drink
and it provides you with good clean
energy
now that we got some talking points from
eat right and feel well.com
you get a 60-day money-back guarantee
keto elevate provides your body with
only c8 the most ketogenic
mct in its purest form that means it
provides very
fast and effective support for and for
enhanced energy levels healthy appetite
management
healthy enhanced enhanced mental clarity
and focus
athletic performance keto elevate is
very gentle on your stomach
five grams of the highly sought after
mctc8 per scoop
it is the most advanced mct powder on
the market today and free shipping
with every order for every order today
biotrust donates a nutritious meal to a
hungry child in your honor
through their partnership with no kid
hungry.org to date
biotrust has provided over 4.4 million
meals to hungry kids so please help
biotrust
hit their goal of 5 million meals this
year you get
free vip live health and fitness
coaching from biotrust team of expert
nutrition
and health coaches for life with every
order and you get their new e-report for
free
the top 14 ketogenic foods with every
order so again go to
eatrightandfeelwell.com 51
off biotrust thank you so much for
sponsoring the show and i'm going to
stress that mike michael malus
mentioned this last time we did an ad
read and he's like you guys got to
understand that each and every one of
these sponsors willing to directly put
their name on the line on these
political podcasts
they are helping make these
conversations and they're helping defend
our values so
i believe in freedom liberty biotrust is
willing to put their name on it in fact
they're they're they're counting on it
to get them to get their name out which
means tremendous amount of respect for
these sponsors willing to
to be involved level they are don't
forget so that's that's
eatrightandfield.com but don't forget go
to timcast.com become a member
we're gonna have a bonus segment coming
up around 11 p.m after the show with all
the fancy
uncensored bits youtube doesn't want us
to say but i also want to mention you
mentioned you don't just get access to
the members only
content we have added a news room where
cassandra fairbanks has been writing a
ton of excellent articles and we are
hiring
hiring hiring we are we are we have just
uh about signed on our paranormal and
mysteries unexplained writer is going to
be doing long form
investigations into a more academic and
research-based approach
approach into these unsolved mysteries
which could be paranormal ufos
or even just ghost stories because we
want to have fun and we want to step
outside the realms of politics why
building culture is extremely important
to winning a culture war
with your support as members we'll be
able to do that now let's jump into that
first
story this is from business politics uh
bizpac review
misguided embrace of mob justice doesn't
end well
for blue check who took on ann coulter
it's an excellent
uh title of the article but i'll just
give you the gist of it because we have
the article here and we have uh ann
coulter
i mentioned this in the opening but for
those who are just joining in there was
a very
there was a very serious tragedy where
uh a man and his girlfriend were
celebrating puerto rican day and they
were flying the flag
in the humboldt park neighborhood of
chicago they got ambushed
somehow they ended up outside of their
car either dragged out or fell out and
they were shot the man was effectively
executed the woman was left for dead
in critical condition and they were
rushed to the hospital this is a
horrifying story
but this blue checkmark on twitter the
founder of a democrat political action
committee
said and you forgot to mention that he
was flying a confederate flag and he was
white
as if that somehow justified murdering a
man in cold blood
and when people called him out he was
like okay i was wrong about the flag i
get that but i was just saying if it was
a white guy
like even doubling down this is this
to me it's a shocking uh example of
where we are today in mainstream
politics
or i i guess this is more worrying
maybe this is just what people have
always thought they just didn't have a
venue to
blast it out to the world when ann
coulter would appear on fox news and say
these things
this guy would probably be sitting in
his lounge chair in his living room
saying the exact same thing
it's only now that we can see what they
think because they're willing to say it
to everybody i guess
truth be told back then without twitter
they probably would have still been
willing to say it they just didn't have
any way to do it
so maybe that's what's really happening
but uh earlier ron you were mentioning
that
you're not even surprised by this and
it's like not even news
no i mean it's news that he that anyone
noticed
[Laughter]
yeah i'll tell you i mean it's only a
couple of clicks away from
last night you know very often so i i
have a
i don't have a tim paul kind of twitter
account but i've got you know 130 some
odd thousand
and a blue check oh you're one of them
i'm blue check two yeah i know of course
yeah blue checkers
and often i will get into
you know i'll i'll scroll down into look
what looks like a fun scrum
and say you know this looks like so i
can i should be able to get a couple of
good one
good one-liners off here that's kind of
my mo
and then i bring the culmination in
that's the name of my podcast
culmination
the coleman although i was really meant
as a pun on culmination
that's a good one like just like the sex
pistols were the band that killed rock
and roll i wanted to be the podcaster
that killed podcasting
but not until i made a ton of money at
it see
um and i
it was an ashley babbitt thread
and inevitably there's some
awful person saying well she got exactly
what she deserved
well it was someone who said ashley webb
got justice on january 6
right that's horrifying oh in that in
every single ashley babbitt threat
so and so often people will say to me
why did i tell you how big my account
was because all people ron while you're
bothering with this person he has seven
other followers
answer i'm not doing it for him
i'm not trying to conv he's he's he is
a moral [ __ ] he's not gonna no one
changes his mind
on twitter we know that
but i do have a lot of people who are
interested in how
ron will deal with this issue or with
this
comment because they look to me
for a certain kind of rhetorical
leadership we might call it
so i sort of started up with this guy
and he
he would was absolutely but you can find
it
all the time you know often i'll say
well breaking and entering
is actually not this well it's breaking
and entering you know you can shoot
soldier
no breaking and entering is in a house
in washington dc it doesn't have to be
at night necessarily but
it isn't a public building that wasn't
breaking and entering second
there is a standard a legal standard for
the use of
force and this didn't resemble that in
the slightest now
as i said this is a couple of clicks
away from
displaying a flag which involves no
violence or threat of violence
there's no misjudgment that was just
plain
murder right this was frankly
i wouldn't want to say anything too too
out there that i've already said on
twitter but i've said it
people are absolutely i think tim you
absolutely nailed it
people just feel comfortable saying it
now
someone who thinks like that has always
thought like that or
they grew up in a house where mom and
pop
or bomb or pop thought like that
that's that that's i think that's the
only thing that's changed well i think
it's possible that
um social media has driven these people
insane in the sense of uh
they like to talk about the rabbit hole
like these new york times reporters and
these nbc reporters
it's not true in the way they think it
is they're like oh youtube's algorithm
makes people go down a rabbit hole which
makes no sense because it's only ever
politics right they make this claim
that if someone watches a video on
immigration within a month they'll be
you know
far right or whatever but if that were
the case that that
there would be a rabbit hole for every
subject it's like you watch a cartoon
about batman
and then the month you've got batman
posters all over your walls and you're
running around the city just like batman
well i've become obsessed with
with world war one flame throwers oh the
originals
anyone getting that one is anyone
getting that reference no it's a thomas
wichter reference
well so so but what i do think happens
though is communities
can rile people up and twitter and
facebook are the actual culprit of
radicalization not so much youtube in
fact
youtube act gives you a big mix because
it doesn't just send you down one
direction
oh i will say though youtube did have
some element of this where it's like you
get the same content over and over
i wouldn't say it radicalized you other
than that it showed you the same thing
over and over on twitter
you do get radicalized because what
happens is you're looking for retweets
and everybody's constantly one-upping
each other to be that top figure the
same thing is true with these blogs like
buzzfeed and with vox and with facebook
you're constantly trying to shock people
into sharing content
youtube doesn't have a direct share
feature the way that twitter and
facebook does
if you want to share a youtube video and
you should share this one by taking the
url and posting it on facebook and
twitter
you have to actually manually do it this
is why it's very very difficult for
youtube centric conversations to expand
to a larger level people who are
watching this have to actually go into
the url copy it
then paste it on another platform or
there's a share but they can click and
then select a platform and then open up
a window
and that platform may or may not preview
well
and if it doesn't it's dead on arrival
now let's let's think about how twitter
and facebook works with this like
radicalization is extremism and this guy
i mean this is literally a story about a
guy
going on twitter saying it was okay for
people to be executed using his own name
there's a real person this is not like
you're verified right it's because when
he tweets
he's hoping someone will hit the retweet
button and on the spot
relay his message to hundreds more
so what happens is people keep trying to
find
what will get them attention when they
find it they attack it like crazy
getting more and more retweets going
more and more insane i want to suggest
that it's not always such an intense
thing i think there's actual in a way
what what i want to say here is a little
scarier even
if you tell me that people are going to
say shocking things in order to get
attention
and this goes back to like the skinheads
the punks
using uh you know swastikas
are they nazis oh johnny rotten has a
swastika therefore he wants to round up
the jews
no no what it means is that he wants to
shock you horrify you get
your attention i'm not saying it's cool
i'm just saying
chill out
what you're seeing a lot of with people
in this
highly politicized environment is casual
casual expressions of
ugly thoughts in other words
i had a tweet i guess it was four three
four days ago
i write these really elaborate threads i
am
i am bringing the very
substance of godly wisdom to my people i
write these
incredibly insightful and original
threads and i often get nice traction
but then listen if you knew how humble i
was being in describing it that way
but i had six thousand tweets for the
following
tweet a quote tweet of biden announcing
that he told the russians the 16 things
they absolutely positively can't do and
i said is this a parody
okay now that went viral
that was a casual that was like a gimme
that was that was this chip
shot i just felt i had to say something
but
i didn't i didn't but it got me a
gazillion followers
or a gazillion clicks you know they're
not too sticky they're not right they're
not too sticky
but there's a people who are very very
active in social media will very just
casually drop their expression
it's sort of like going to the bathroom
like oh you know i have to
i have to eliminate i have to eliminate
you know i
i've built up too many
things about how stupid trump people i
need to just say that
so in other words i think in a way
that's worse because that's become
you know part of that by the way if you
want to talk are you saying that uh
twitter is basically
like a a septic tank of bad ideas like
people you build up this idea waste and
then
onto twitter and then everyone swims in
it and basks in these ideas
i think we're gonna have to think about
that a little bit
but i think you might be on to something
i think that's certainly i mean you know
what's really funny
my twitter is just like i love twitter i
hated it for a long time and then i
realized you have to love it
and uh again shout out to michael malus
because he's the master at this but i
was just like i have learned so much
technique
from malice genius i posted it so
i was watching the movies the other day
he was a genius and um my girlfriend
mentioned that uh
like we were watching a movie where a
rabbit got run over
and you know i was jokingly like oh i
can't watch the movie anymore oh no a
rabbit's been killed it was a horror
movie i was kidding
and then uh the rabbit was by far the
least
sentient thing that was killed in that
movie for sure for sure but i i made
uh we we basically came upon the joke
that there's no such thing as an ugly
rabbit it was like a cute animal that
was killed
and so i googled it ugly rabbit and boy
are there ugly rabbits
so i just tweeted without a comment for
no reason
a picture of a hairless rabbit eating
kale
that was very wearing a scarf very silly
looking
because that's my twitter and i love it
because i tweet things and i get these
very serious replies from these people
like
you know this is probably and i'm like
bro i just posted a picture of a
hairless rabbit eating kale
who do you think you're interacting with
twitter is not the place
for me to have a serious little
conversation but i'll post serious
things there
no it's like a a waste pit of just like
stupid things that i think i'm going to
tweet i just don't care anymore
there i don't know during the election
it was different there was so much going
on politically that i'd think of
something and be like man i can't
believe this and i just
tweet it to no one in particular and
then i just got to a point where i was
like this
is an awful vile place where people just
like
want to kill each other it's it's the
fence between people for which they can
bark at each other
and so i just decided you know what i
just post insane nons at this point and
i practice law
so to me i'm i'm new to that i mean
the fact is it's a lot of what law is
right well you know ridiculous arguments
i will tell you
really some of the finest people to hang
out with are
lawyers and and i mean the kind of
lawyers who are my kind of lawyers who
are
who try cases in the courts during a
break or while waiting
for a judge the vast majority of the
lawyers
that i encounter in my work they're such
a pl they're such a pleasure
i really like there's a there's a real a
real cool
aspect to that but on the other hand
as a whole in the work that we do
there's so much toleration
for falsehood
and dishonesty and i don't only mean at
the lawyer level
i mean also at the judicial level and
also at the appellate level
that you really do become very used to
that septic tank phenomenon
unfortunately
um we're swimming in it so yeah i do
think that there is this sense that
that there's a sort of casual a casual
nastiness
that we didn't have in society before
you know you always had people who wrote
nasty letters to the editor
the editors didn't print them right the
others didn't print them
or it was the shopper and they needed
content and there was just always the
cranky guy you always complained about
why don't people put you know the
shopping carts away
you know in the stop and shop you know
and that was their world
and yeah you know the first iteration of
this was
chain letters it's they started the
physical world
somebody'd get a letter in the mail and
it would open it would be like you have
been cursed
like i wonder how many young people
realize these were physical letters did
you ever get a physical chain letter
sure of course
i i remember when i was literally mine
was delivered by pony express you have
to keep in mind
but you're only 40 years ago yeah 30
years ago so uh anyway
um i i i think a lot of young people
think chain letters just started with
email
may not realize that people used to
physically mail chain like you must mail
this to 17 people
but i remember the early emails the goal
was to get maximum
echo to to to impact the world
so that people would do your thing it
would have it's a similar reason why
people write computer viruses
they want to make something influential
have an impact
graffiti right even when i was a kid so
i was growing up in
in brooklyn in this in the late 60s and
70s
when the city began its first massive
down cycle
and people started writing on public
services this was something if you look
at photographs from the through the
1950s and early 60s
of even the most decrepit stations
there was no idea that people would
write on
stuff and even as a child i recognized
because i was an extremely socially
aware child that
the people doing this obviously
are desperate to make a mark in the
world to make them
and and far be it from me
right with my 70 000 tweets a week
to look down on someone who wants to
make a mark in the world
i get it i get it and especially the
more powerless you are the
the more of a mark sometimes you want to
make because the
you know a person who is well adjusted
and who has
normal interaction with people makes a
mark by making his children happy by
making his spouse happy but
you know but there are lots of normal
healthy ways to do it
in an idealized almost non-existent kind
of existence
and then come the other and some people
need that
less and some people need it more
everyone needs to feel
valued and if you're not can't be valued
then you're going to then you're going
to shock the world
and twitter is this attention yes it is
absolutely is this a point system
you earn points your retweets are points
your likes are points your followers are
points
your followers are your ranking where
you are in the game
and when twitter does one of its purges
and i and when they purged the cue
people
i lost 30 000 in a week wow
now most of those people were lunatics
so you know but what about the leftist
lunatics who are tweeting things like
this
no no they get a free pass on all of it
look there you've had that there's an
article going viral right now
where in 2018 newsweek was arguing that
hillary clinton could still become
president
a year into trump's presidency i
remember that very well
now you will get banned from youtube if
you say the same thing about trump right
now
if you say the same thing the same thing
we won't say
that's right that's right in fact
amazing
but but that's but that's passe we have
come to
accept that that's the way our masters
insist that we proceed but
but you know it is
it is this point system and but so when
they take away a massive amount of
followers from you
and now imagine when they ban somebody
so i'm one of the people who gets dm'd
or emailed when someone gets banned
because they think they think for a
reason that
does not exist by the way that i'm the
guy who can help them
because you're a lawyer i'm a lawyer and
i'm the free speech lawyer
and i'm really active on twitter
and i'm a blue check
and i'm powerful i'm not i'm not
powerful at all
when i write letters and i gave up a
long time ago
to the head of the legal department at
twitter
she doesn't even bother to respond right
she doesn't bother responding and by the
way you know who invented
talk about a hyperlink talk about your
adhd special moment
you know who invented the concept in my
in my 40 years on this planet since
1963.
my observation is that the concept of
absolutely ignoring your customers
for a private company that was not
actually like a utility
was microsoft the first company that
made you
buy an expensive
something from them and that you had no
expectation whatsoever
that if you had a problem or a question
that they were going to help you
monopoly power that is the way right
because what's because what's a utility
a regulated monopoly right and when you
see a company acting
like a utility ding-a-ling-ling-ling
well you've got a monopoly so let's talk
a bit about defamation in section 230
because uh you're a lawyer right that's
a terrible segue too
that's actually pretty good we're
talking about big taxes
well we're talking about uh censorship
you've got uh people conservatives
getting banned left and right queue gets
purged
but the rachel maddow conspiracy nuts
are given free pass right
so so i want to ask you a question
because i can't remember what was
talking about i think i was talking to
will chamberlain about this
and we've brought up several times for
those that aren't familiar section 230
basically gives broad immunities to
web what what's the phrase they use um
interactive
web companies or internet service
providers there you go there you go
that basically means everybody for any
reason okay so what happens is
they can ban whoever they want
regardless of speech because they are
immunized from defamation as well as
long story short they won't have the
immunity taken from them if they do
moderate
however what's been happening is very
obviously
most of the bans happen on the right or
anti-establishment
some of the bans happen on the left but
it's usually like anti-war
anti-establishment leftist types
now the problem is many people on the
right seem to think there's a
distinction between a publisher and a
platform as if it matters it really
doesn't
the new york times has the same
protections as twitter
but something interesting does arise out
of this argument that i want to present
to you
first i'll start with uh the new york
times for instance right
if somebody writes for the writes an
article
and the new york times publishes on its
front page
what's the distinction between that and
say
someone writing a tweet and twitter
publishing it and putting it in it's
what's happening bar to everybody
in the world oh
putting it in the in the what's
happening bar right
that's a much harder question because if
you would have just told if you would
you should have asked
two questions the first question was
what's the difference between the times
publishing an article and a tweet
we that's dumb though right obvious
questions right and that's why i see
twitter is just mechanically so i don't
know how they choose articles
for the what's happening bar they
editorialize oh they select a tweet and
then they write about it
or tweets okay so if they select a tweet
based on algorithms
the selection piece of it might be
content neutral in and of itself
although their algorithms are not
content neutral at all
but if they editorialize see
again we have to ask ourselves what's
what do we what what's the inquiry here
why do we care about this distinction
the the the simple answer to your
question is there's no difference
they are now publishers they are now
putting content into the world
for which they have the same
responsibility
as any as the new york times so when so
if john smith writes an article and the
new york times says we're going to put
that on the front page
the new york times is responsible for
the content in terms of live
defamation slander whatever libel right
okay if someone writes a tweet and then
twitter says we're going to put this in
our moment step so everybody
can see it well curious as to what's the
difference but what's the editorial
but okay so you said they editorialized
it's a really well
let's let's make sure i clarify this so
they though what's happening
they'll put an editorialization that's
usually in reference to a series of
tweets so i understand
they're liable for what they write there
but if i write an article for the new
york times
and then hand it to a guy and he goes i
will publish this in the front page
right he's new york times assumes
responsibility for the contents of the
of that post if someone tweets and
twitter goes
i am going to put this in the moments
tab so that anyone who clicks it will
see it front and center
to hundreds of millions of people what's
the difference
it depends on what the reasonable
viewer understands from that tweet
and that's a fact question that has
never been
examined in a in a litigation setting
because
cases don't go this far and they need to
because i got another question for you
especially if i'm handling them because
i would love to ask those questions
let me ask you a question if ian wrote
an article
and posted it on his blog and then i
took the contents of that article and
put on the front page of my website
would i assume responsibility for
publishing it
are you more than an aggregator are you
drudge report or are you this is to
this is tim poole and these are the
articles that i want you to read because
it it it appears on my front page
identically to every other article
every other so that's your newspaper in
other words
so if he licensed it he licensed the
article to you with the publisher so
if on your twitter account there's a
retweet from ian
that appears identically to your other
posts would your retweet then be
your responsibility as well yes
see this is where there's a lot of
questions that have never been asked and
we haven't seen people actually go to
court and start
challenging but this is one of the least
important questions see
and this as you understand because
you've spoken to will about this and
this is like a favorite
ron and will thing we wrote articles on
this together
it hardly matters you know
the publisher versus platform
distinction is mostly irrelevant because
it has to do with
to what extent is twitter responsible
for what people tweet
meaning if i defame you in a tweet can
you sue twitter
why would you want to suit twitter
because coleman doesn't have any money
well coleman's not making it happen
twitter is the one giving youtube
i write a tweet that says
nancy pelosi is an alcoholic i have it
on good authority antipolicy an
alcoholic
drinks a fifth of gin every half an hour
okay
i put it on twitter you you can't sue
twitter no matter how
obvious of a lie it is because they're
just
they're just a mechanism they're just an
internet service provider you can sue
coleman
but i want to sue twitter because
they've got billions of dollars
and coleman has half a house in new
jersey okay
and if pelosi can prove damages by the
time she gets past my mortgage
it's not going to be worth the trouble
that's why we care
but we hardly care because most
because section 230 says you're not
going it's not going to happen but
defamation is hardly ever the issue
the issue is the censorship and that's
where
the cases are getting interesting
especially now that we have the
the rogan o'hanley case that we filed
last week
what is this one rogan
rogan handling known as dc drano
sued twitter but it's twitter is the
last party
in the defendant column the first party
is the secretary of state
of the state of california
rogan got documents from judicial watch
smoking gun documents showing that
under the guise of
election security
the state of california was
sending and through through a consultant
and in cooperation with 22 members of
the national association of secretaries
of state
all democrats sending tweets
that were selected i think by the
consultant
to twitter saying this is misleading
this is fake news a direct line from
democrats
to the big tech company no they are all
democrats
a direct line from the government there
you go to the censorship
a direct all we've heard about is
you build your own twitter the
government and twitter
are the same
the government you know
there's been lots of talk about what
kind of accommodations have been made
we won't regulate you if you play ball
all this
that's all very sort of impressionistic
what we have here is specific political
instructions from political
activists telling
twitter and they banned
dc draeno has two million
instagram followers meaning
it they just needed a a
a an excuse
he's too influential to be allowed to
continue to comment
on twitter as far as i know instagram is
not implicated in this in facebook
in this particular issue but
this is where things are going this is
where things are going so
now that's almost the first that's
a new world that's a new world and we
this is a case that we filed on thursday
and it's being routinely ignored by the
media
completely ignored if i told you fox
won't cover it
they won't fox will not cover it
wow and
i always knew that tucker carlson was
controlled opposition
so tucker so rogen and harmeet my
partner
were on tucker thursday night but fox
news won't cover it
but tucker allowed you to talk about it
tucker i take her back he's the only one
who's not controlling that position
talk you know that you know these
categories are both
baloney
you know and it's very common on on
twitter that people want to
you know have he's a rhino
uh he oh that bill of democrats support
it the world is not black and white
and there's no question that in politics
you have to make accommodations to get
things done
with uh people from other parties and i
you know we all have to get that
people are complicated they have you
know unlike you you know we were talking
before we went on
who's who's sticking their neck out for
the movement versus who's sticking his
neck out for his 401k
you know and listen most people are not
most people are just interested in i
don't want to call it a grift
making a living you know making a living
or making a
building a big business but there is one
individual that i would like to i'd like
to ask you about in terms of the
conversation uh james o'keefe
because if there's one person i think is
you know the real deal in terms of
sticking his neck out and you know
uh jumping into the fray the tip of the
spear as it were as he
james o'keefe is fighting the fight and
more so than most people
he's for real yeah he's legit and he's
doing a lot of great work and he's
winning a lot of important battles
but if you go to his wikipedia page
you'll notice that it is
the most insane garbled propaganda it is
if what's uh what's the word for
defamation but like
100 orders of magnitude larger that's
what it is
and it's amazing because the wikipedia
page for james o'keefe is very clearly
an
op-ed it is not in any way fact-based
now my question is how does wikipedia
get away
with smearing james o'keefe the way they
they do and i'll i'll
elaborate on this we've talked about it
before uh they say project well not
necessarily james keeps specifically
they do smear him but project veritas
they say it's far right it's an activist
group
they produce deceptive video edits you
know secret coordinates
entrapment um generating bad publicity
it's propagate propagating
disinformation conspiracy theories
now all of these are this this page from
wikipedia
the citations are opinion pieces
wikipedia doesn't say it's the
the free opinion aggregator it says it's
the free encyclopedia which is an actual
definition what encyclopedia is
so i'm sure there's some kind of
argument they can make well look
someone's opinion
it you know somebody chooses to cite it
as a you know as a fact in here that's
not us
here's here's the question i have work
it's interesting if
i post a tweet saying james o'keefe once
uh ate a whole pizza by himself a large
pepperoni uh and it's not true i have
defamed him i have libeled him right
only if that's something that would
constitute i mean that might be a
positive statement depending on sure
let's say i said james o'keefe did bad
thing and it results in him losing tons
of money and donors
and it's not true so he says here's the
damages you've defamed me you've libeled
me and i'm suing you for damages
twitter says don't look at us that says
tim poole checkmark and the tweet
clearly came from him
section 230 not on us right it would be
on me personally
if it's your tweet correct right well
when i pull up project veritas on
wikipedia
it says from wikipedia
project veritas from wikipedia the free
encyclopedia
the name attached to this post is
wikipedia not john smith
or bill hammond or
edgar allan poe literally wikipedia i
can understand the argument that when
someone posts something in their names
next to it it's their statement
but what wikipedia is doing is
displaying no names
if i want to figure out who added one
section to this i might have to dig
through hundreds of pages no because
wikipedia has already decided that we
have taken other people's comments and
crafted it into an article we put our
name on
at what point is this wikipedia speech
especially when they say it's from them
tim you've given me much to unpack here
but we have time
first before i say anything else i have
to say
that we also represent james o'keefe and
project veritas
ah right on and we have two pending
lawsuits that we filed in the last month
or so
which were which earned me ice cream
and my followers will understand that
that's how i reward myself and i've done
a great job
um that's number one so
there's on the one hand i will have to
limit my
comments on the other hand you'll i'm
also telling you that i'm biased but no
more
i'm no more biased than i was before
because like you
you look at james o'keefe and you know
he's absolutely the real deal let's not
even uh
i just pull up project veritas simply
because it's very obvious definition but
let's say
literally anything else let's say uh uh
you know my pillow
so i'm not sure that that section 230
covers wikipedia at all
i don't think it's an internet service
provider i don't know if that's been
tested but as you said whom do you sue
the problem there is corporate
accountability
let me just point out though that
the reason we care i i think it is
there's that there's a consensus
in the political and policy and
internet part that we occupy
that wikipedia is garbage
unless you're looking up species of
butterflies
and you know the most generic stuff but
anything
juicy anything it's known at this point
to be
garbage but here's the problem
google considers it a highly
authoritative right resource
that's why we have to break up google
because
google which is not an internet service
provider as such
search engine google editorializes
and manipulates results for political
purposes
and it has a right to do just like
people also know that google's garbage
but you know what i don't want to say
the name
of the alternative search engine that i
use because i don't want to hurt i don't
want to hurt their business
but so if i want to look up species of
butterflies it's fine
but if i really need to get information
i'm inevitably going to
end up back at google and having to use
my
super brain to get past the bias because
these guys their search engine's not as
good it's not as good
you know bing's a little bit better
actually
but it's not with the wikipedia part
it's the way it and this is not this is
this is an
aspect of network effects it's the way
that
that wikipedia has been baked into
google and so is twitter
and there's been extremely little
attention paid
to the partnership between google and
twitter i i see what you're saying about
wikipedia if you google search someone's
name there's a box that appears and has
wikipedia information which could be
completely made up and there's been very
funny stories about people having their
wikipedia changed by random users and
then it appears on google
which then transfers to your you know
amazon or google device so you're at
home and then you'll
ask your little computer who was you
know george washington and they'll be
like he was a pancake salesman
because somebody edited wikipedia the
system's fairly fractured if you guys
mean
but i think the attack vector in terms
of challenging
this malfeasance is sure you could argue
breaking up google
but sue wikipedia
i mean so was i knows they desperately
need your donations they won't shut up
about it i
i'm sure it's been tried i know that
i've seen the case captions i think the
issue with wikipedia is
i think they might actually the the
corporate
home of wikipedia is somewhere that's
not in this country
it's in some country
that isn't going to work out too well
for litigation
something like that and and also one
that probably
is not as amenable to
[Music]
um disclosure as the united states it's
not
well it's ukraine but you know it's so
let's think about the
the the problem we're facing there this
is something that i've had a lot of
concerns about going into the 2020
election
twitter will ban a conservative for
saying their opinion an american citizen
with a political opinion on twitter will
get banned
but an australian citizen who has a
contradictory opinion that supports the
left will be allowed to get all the
retweets in the world
so you actually have foreign influence
so long as it supports the agenda of one
faction
gaining traction and being protected
while american citizens i'll tell you
this
laura loomer might be considered by many
to be distasteful or they don't like her
they think she's bombastic or just they
really don't like her because
oh you know because she's high energy
we'll call her that
but she's an extremely enthusiastic
young lady yes she's an american citizen
who has a right to speak and be engaged
in politics whether you like it or not
but she's removed from every platform
meanwhile i see it on reddit
every day someone will comment on
american news there's a little
australian new zealand flag a canadian
flag a russian flag
why do these people get to influence and
be involved in our conversation but our
own american citizens aren't allowed
i'll do you one better
first i'll say that laura loom is also
my client oh my
well good good right on and one of the
things that
we tried to argue and the judges simply
they use section 230 to just get rid of
any
we don't think they're going to be able
to do this with the handily case with
the dc draenor case because of the
government
action it's just too over the top but
in laura's case our argument essentially
was
you know the first amendment prohibits
the government from censoring
the speech of citizens but only the u.s
government
what if care let's just say the council
on american
arab america what is it council on
american
islamic relations let's just say they
accepted money from a foreign government
a nasty foreign government and that
foreign government
told care
here's what you need to do here are
there voices you need to silence in
order for us to more effectively message
on this issue and
qatar just for example therefore decides
that laura loomer should be censored
the first amendment has nothing to say
about that
twitter takes orders from we know
twitter takes orders
i don't know about twitter we know that
there's an issue with
with platforms and and and technology
companies taking orders from china
yeah also from europe from european
governments that have
restricted anti-hate laws right well
what we're really talking about here is
the fact that
the the technology companies
are themselves not beholden to any
particular
government they are bigger than
sovereign states they are more powerful
and wealthier than most sovereign states
in the world
and libertarians say
build your own twitter dude
they are already the emperors well
it's actually it's really simple then uh
i think by outlining this problem
all we got to do is ask our politicians
to regulate these companies to prevent
the four
interference now i know the democrats
probably greatly benefit from that
interference but
i'm sure they'll see reason right
well i'll tell you something on the
culmination podcast
i actually interviewed representative
ken buck last week
who has introduced a bill to do just
that and it's a bipartisan bill hey
that's great
it's a bipartisan bill and and it's it
is more oriented towards
antitrust enforcement than to censorship
per se
but as we have just demonstrated
they're intimately related because
if you have the only platform that
matters
doesn't matter whether i've got an
alternative it's an ultra i'm
like yeah i can go into the room with
all the beanbags in it downstairs to
scream my head off
so i have freedom of speech but no one's
going to hear me
so after i after i i get you canceled
because of this
you know episode of tim in real life
that's gonna be the same thing for you
imagine if uh before the age of the
internet
fox news kept putting vladimir putin on
prime time to talk about how americans
should vote and people listened and they
voted the way he said
i mean that would be insane you know we
we we couldn't imagine
something like that happening then we
get four or five years of them screaming
that donald trump was
the benefactor of just that well quite
literally there are foreign governments
influencing through social media either
investing in companies and getting some
say in them
or actually just being extremely wealthy
foreign
high-ranking officials put it that way
political figures making demands and
promising favors and it happens our
political system is corrupted if that's
the case
and i don't see why you know even if you
know ken buck does propose this
legislation
i'm not confident for one that democrats
would want to give up the freebies
they're getting
and the republicans are too stupid to do
anything about it so there are a couple
things going on i asked him
why are democrats in on this and i think
he acknowledged
their concerns are not the same concerns
as ours
but there is
to some extent i think he agreed with my
suggestion that now that trump
is gone whatever that really means
i mean i think we all understand that he
is running the country from a
nuclear submarine off the coast um
although many people who are banned from
twitter would probably wish
fortunately he's not um
although i will i will tell you if you
ask alexa
don't turn on please i just yelled at me
alexa stopped
apparently apparently i shouldn't say
the name ever again
uh apparently it says that trump is the
president
and and like people are laughing and
hooting like this it's always
amazon says it it's like okay dude it's
a stupid computer program
so i must admit that even i lost
even i lost the thread there um sorry
about that
no that's okay anything for a good gag
especially
when you're gonna get you're talking
about uh asking the democrats why they
were in on it
so there i i think the world
is a little bit safer for democrats to
actually be democrats when they don't
have to merely oppose something because
it benefits donald trump
i'm not still sure why there's some why
there seems i mean
biden appointed as head of the federal
trade commission so
everybody understands right there are
two
agencies in the u.s government that are
mainly in charge of anti-trust
enforcement one is the anti-trust
division of the justice department
which is a relatively more political
agency compared to the federal trade
commission
which focuses more on mergers and
acquisitions but which is also involved
in an industry consul industry
shares and domination um because that's
obviously part and parcel of
acquisitions that's traditionally
considered
considered to be a less political agency
biden
appointed and she was approved as ftc
commissioner
a woman who has a reputation as being a
critic of big tech
now those of us such as myself who have
been saying for six months that
joe biden is what is called in
hebrew a golem being like basically a
zombie a puppet incapable of independent
thought he's just you know
weekend of bernie's kind of situation
it's hard for me not to believe that
that he is in which case
for some reason the powers that be
either want to do this incredibly
elaborate false flag operation like at
some point you have to start believing
that maybe things
may appear to be what they are or maybe
there is still a constituency within the
democrat party and by the way i'm not so
sure that
the squad isn't part of that
constituency
that doesn't like big business
and sees these global corporations
because remember
to to to a real progressive a
preposterous term
to a real leftist the state has to have
all the power
even if you tell me well but no but
google and all these
technology companies have been
integrated into this state they're all
the same
not so fast they want to be able to
press a button
as officer so well this is the best
they're going to get i mean the
government can't literally censor but
they can do this
highly circuitous method which you know
you're now suing over right so so
if that's the case if there actually
might be some sort of
bipartisan so what we see though is that
so today there was a tweet from
uh from congressman jordan jim jordan
saying why would i want to give joe
biden's regulators more power
over over business answer
what else you got jim what else have you
got
trump certainly wasn't getting anything
done george
w bush got nothing republican this idea
that republicans should reflexively be
the friends of big business is a joke we
see where big business has been
on the blm you know
this is the thing about republicans too
often
they're saying i opened the door for tim
to trash republicans absolutely i'm
gonna
excuse myself for a few minutes now oh
we'll talk about it
how how often have you heard a
republican advocate for something
like here's what i want here's what
republicans need here's what my
constituents are asking for
do you want to specific oh i hardly ever
hear that tim
do you do i ever hear it yeah you know i
hear a lot of
mostly the left demanding a moratorium
on deportations i hear the left
demanding to shut down the child migrant
facilities
i hear the left demanding the defense of
the facilities when biden's
involved i hear that the the demands
that we allow refugees and i hear the
demand
for abolishing private health care and
then a republican saying
no we shouldn't do that no we shouldn't
do that no we shouldn't do that right
it's reactive marjorie taylor greene
proposes abolishing the atf hey there's
a republican saying let's do something
so she's got to be stopped
well that's exactly what's happening and
we dig up and the republicans are
preposter yeah they do that's right so
so so not only do the republicans
very rarely ever actually propose
anything for their constituents but when
you finally get someone who does
marjorie taylor green they're actively
attacking her from the republican party
that's right i'll tell you something
about her okay so i am
allowed to rack on republicans for that
am i right oh absolutely i mean listen
if harmeet were sitting here my partner
harmy dylan
so she's a big monkey in the republican
party but i'm not and she knows that i'm
not
so i have to be gentle but i don't have
to be as
actually she's not so gentle either
she's got her issues i will tell you
that
marjorie taylor green i i had a column
in the forward which is
a jewish publication it used to be the
predominant
yiddish language jewish newspaper in new
york
explaining that with marjorie taylor
greene said about
uh the vaccination badges being
equivalent to the yellow stars that the
jews have to wear
in in pre-war europe i'm sorry during
the war
in germany also pre-war germany and
everyone clutched their pearls oy dionte
semitism let me i don't know a jewish
an orthodox jew didn't make that joke in
2020.
what are they gonna make us do next
where yellow stars every
year but this one i think i made it you
gotta make it pay when you do it
everyone made that because they were
drawing red lines around jewish
neighborhoods and jewish synagogues
in places like rockland county new york
yeah another lawsuit that i brought
they were chaining parks shut the the
you would have the same and there would
be no epic
epidemiological basis for it it was just
how do we keep these hacienda out of
this synagogue because
it's understood that i see them with a
problem and they were drawing lines like
through up and dropped driveways and
around flower beds
i mean crazy stuff
every everyone knew what was going on
and the reference to being treated like
you know jews in a ghetto was ubiquitous
and these people who were all of a
sudden are standing up and
and and offended by margaret margaret
marjorie marger taylor green
where were they when hitler was when
israel's compared to
to the to the nazis where silent
they don't care right now i'm seeing
leftists post how dare they deny
communion to joe biden and i'm like when
have you ever cared about
the the bishop's rulings on you know
catholic doctrine
when does joe biden never care
all of a sudden they're like jumping out
of the woodwork to clutch
other people's pearls about religion
they never liked in the first
place joe joe you're out of bed again
what's the problem
i i just haven't had communion again
another sunday without
with the wafer i am outraged
how dare they deny john these are people
who rag on the church all day and night
now
flabbergasted and outraged and demand
making demands
and i'm just like you know what man i i
i
these these people who are active on
twitter in these arguments
they can't possibly believe the things
they're saying can they
like how do you how do you rag on
christianity over and over again there's
entire reddits subreddit dedicated to
this and then also now be
outraged that joe biden has been denied
his communion well you know i had a
reason opportunity to
to to wade into those waters myself
recently when somebody said
well nobody really believes in leviticus
anymore
yeah excuse me
[Laughter]
you know no one really does actually no
we
everything oh are you sacrificing i know
you have to understand
how jewish law works okay
there are conditions that have to that
have to be met they don't want to hear
about it
so your question do they really believe
this
answer yeah they do because
you know about seven or eight years ago
i think it is now
they made a change of twitter to to
reduce conflict
and they enhanced the siloization the
ghettoization of twitter
and to some extent it has reduced conf i
i think it's not
there's something to be said for what
they did because you're not always
fighting with people
on the other hand you don't want it to
be like parlor where it's just a bunch
of people not stop screaming mega mega
you know it's completely it's boring
it's i i mean
but what they did was that was
people really reinforced their
prejudices and there's this constant
bias confirmation
and it doesn't have to come from new
facts it could just come from those
likes
right and come from those retweets that
you say i'm right about this
so just like the casual the casual
hatred and the casual repetition of
how stupid donald trump i mean the
things that people convinced themselves
of
that weren't even necessary
oh my gosh so
so i've got this case where i'm
representing carby duncan remember carpe
dunk oh yeah yeah where's he been
well they kicked him off twitter that's
right and the reason they kicked him off
twitter was because
of a copyright claim that's supposedly
been made against him because he did a
meme
with the two little kids the white the
traveler and the black
there was no copyright claim it was it
was fake
he was they just needed an excuse to get
him off twitter
they then so the people who made the
claim the original people who made that
video
sued carpe in new york state court
wrote logan cook for
this preposterous series of um
claims that he was
misleading and basically everything but
defamation but it was basically
defamation
defaming these two little toddlers
nobody knows even knows who they are
and and we had oral argument on our
motion to dismiss
via zoom last week and the lawyer
for the lawyer for um
for the plaintiffs is arguing
to this this new york state supreme
court judge and we all know that the
supreme court in new york doesn't mean
the highest court it means
just bigger than the other courts like
the civil court the traffic court
um that
they really had a good claim here
because
donald trump first one of the donald
everything donald trump
oh so one of our defenses was this can't
be a violation of sections 1551 of the
new york civil rights law because those
only deal with the misappropriation of a
person's
likeness in connection with a sale or
advertisement
a product or a good and this is just a
meme
like poor old copy did
and i said no because really he did it
to please his master donald trump
completely made up and trump
it's well established that everything
trump did during his presidency
was meant to enrich him personally
and the judge looked at this guy this is
not to be a judge in new york
in the state of new york in the city of
new york in the county of new york
you're a democrat okay he looked at this
guy
as if he were from mars you're saying
everything donald trump did
was so that he could make money he said
well yeah because look he made all this
all these golf tournaments didn't barack
obama get a pretty nice
book deal after he left office
are we going to say that everything a
politician does while in office
is commercial like he could but this
lawyer was arguing
it was like blood was going to come out
of his eyes
he was so committed to the truth like in
other words
he knew this to be true the way you and
i know that
h2o is what makes up water he knew it
people believe these myths that donald
trump absolutely
you know worked for worked for the
russians
that he personally benefited
economically from being president and
that's the only reason he did it
that he's a racist i'm a new yorker
donald trump has been part of the scene
in new york
that i've been aware of for for
40 years for me in other words since i
was born
um you never ever ever heard anyone
call him a racist it was just the
opposite he won awards yeah you know
those rewards are
they're pretty much negotiable currency
let's not kid ourselves about that but i
mean i i love using the pictures with
him and jesse jackson that's fine
but the point is they believe it
with their hearts and trump is an
anti-semite his grandchildren are jewish
the worst kind well let's uh let's let's
let's take that
up with uh mr eric weinstein so uh eric
has a tweet thread saying
essentially that no one really believes
in woke ideology
so i had a conversation this a
conversation about this last week but
let's let's read what eric says
and i'm going to say this i agree with
him but uh i'll read
eric says hyper unpopular view i don't
think a single person on earth
believes ideology any soul who truly
quote
identifies as an eagle would be
instantly eliminated by testing the
hypothesis
i think he's implying the person would
like you know jump off a building
but i don't know who enterprise is an
eagle so but says a person who believed
two plus two equals five would be unable
to file taxes
that's a real good point if you're gonna
make an argument about this
a semantic argument about integers and
what determines two plus two equaling
four or five
how do you function on a day-to-day
basis but all read on
he says get woke go broke is nowhere
near extreme enough truly believing in
wokeness could get you jailed or killed
my hypothesis is that every single soul
espousing wokeness critical theory
etc is doing so disingenuously and
without exception
that is why it can't be defeated by
reason wokeness is reveling in the idea
that it makes no sense
the only ones believing it are those
fighting it further this is why
inclusion
is at its core a strategy because the
remedy for wokeness wasting the energy
of
the developed world by boring us to
death is to exclude it
not on the base of it being wrong but
because the saboteur must always be
excluded from civic life
let me give other positions so extreme
they are primophasia disingenuous
crypto toxic bitcoin maxillism hyper
conservatives
we need a strong defense in a dangerous
world but also all taxes theft etc
all of these are parasitic on someone
else being the adult
i agree with him that the woke do not
believe
any of their ideology and i don't
i don't know of anybody who identifies
as an eagle so i don't know what that's
a reference to
but i understand the point he's trying
to make to a certain degree
i do think the two plus two equaling
equaling five is a good point to be made
because they're there is it is a hill
they're absolutely willing to die on
where where now you have i think like an
mit
mathematician coming out making a video
explaining how two plus two
could equal five and if that's an
assumption you could make
then at what point in your taxes do you
say i think this one's gonna be a four
and that one's gonna be a five well
the couple things one is that because
because the what we're calling the
wokeness
initiative i'm i added the word
initiative
the initiative of what we're calling
wokeness is
destructive and subversive
they want to live in a world where they
can say to the irs
oh no i say it's five and to say i'm
wrong makes you a racist
right so it gives them the ability to
determine when it is true or not to
benefit themselves so his argument that
no that won't work because you'll go to
the
he wants to be able to go out into the
bank and change
get changed for a 10 and come back with
a hundred okay
that's that's part of the goal but i
think there's another problem here which
is that
he tends to hang around with very smart
people like you and me
but we know more dumb people than he
does there are a lot
of really dumb people
michael malus midwifes not even that
dumb
well they're actually smart midwifes
smart enough to
simulate high intelligence but in fact
to be
mediocre thinkers who
i believe are buying it and they are
because we're underestimating the power
the marvelous wonderful power of
cognitive dissonance
it doesn't add up it will come to we all
read 1984
you come around eventually to believing
that
the right thing because it lets your
brain relax the social pressure is off
yes i am a racist you know what i've
said a million times
and no one ever retweets it because
they're afraid
if all these white chicks and they're
mostly chicks
hating themselves for being white hating
themselves for being
hating whiteness and wish if they woke
up
black they would walk right out the
window
they would kill themselves they're
racists they
would they're the biggest racist in the
world and if you disagree with me
you're you're you are a racist because
if i'm right if i'm wrong then you're
telling me no you're not you're raised
if i'm wrong then there is not
actually systemic racism and if i'm
right that there is systemic racism
we see that the systemic racism makes
hypocrites out of all these people
bemoaning their whiteness
pretty good huh ron called me for the
win well yeah
i i don't think that uh the way i
described it last week is i don't think
they actually believe this stuff but
it's impossible to believe two
contradictory things at the same time
unless of course we're suggesting
they're suffering from cognitive
dissonance
these are the kind of people that will
say the sky is blue and the sky is green
to your face in the same sentence
they can't simultaneously well do what
you say
say that they are racists and that
racists are bad
but they are good that's just i'll tell
you this you ever see these videos where
it's like a white guy's like on tick
tock and he's like telling everybody how
racist he is
if anybody ever came up to me a white
person and started talking about
critical race theory or critical theory
and then said that they were a racist
i'd be like and now you can stop talking
because you're a racist and it's time
for you to sit down to listen
congratulations your own ideology says
shut up
sit down but nobody does this no you
know one of the things that really
bothers me is i keep hearing about
people quitting their jobs because
they're being trained critical race
through things like this
and i'm like so what you're telling me
is that they your workplace is violating
the civil rights act of 1964 is that
title
vii i think and you just quit you see
here's the problem
these leftists will use anything to
claim as racism
and they'll get away with it how about
this we had this story out of
out of seattle that i'll just pull up
reparations fee to be charged
for white people at seattle gay pride
event well we're now hearing
the seattle human rights commission has
dismissed the complaint saying that well
you know you got to look at history and
recognize that this is actually okay
all right so they're willing to look at
overt racial discrimination
and say it's not okay now i understand
this is a challenge
the eeoc may be full of woke individuals
who refuse to accept your complaints
but if you work it if you work at a
company the moment someone says the word
white anything you can now claim
they're being racist it's their rules
for example
here's what here's what i've said on the
show before if they say we're gonna have
a discussion on
white privilege you just stop them and
say excuse me did you just bring all
these people
in here to learn about white
benefits like why why it's better to be
white do you think that's okay to like
why do we have a conversation about
non-whiteness why did you think
whiteness was the appropriate subject
you're a racist you're white supremacist
you're having a clan meeting no matter
what they say the moment they say
anything related to race
you can claim racism the right doesn't
do this
and perhaps because they think they're
fighting fair but
i'll tell you this you know if you think
you're playing you know let me slow down
i'll do a different analogy
we're playing a game monopoly we're
watching the other side pull bills out
of the out of the bank
in our front of our faces and we go hey
wait you can't do that
and they're like yeah i can and you go
okay and you keep playing and then
you're like why do i keep losing i don't
understand
how did you have so much money to buy
boardwalk and park place and put hotels
on it
i don't know i guess i'll never figure
it out but i did see you taking all that
money you're not supposed to do oh well
that sounds like the discussion about
the um
election audits in what way what do you
mean
why do you why are you suppressing votes
by doing election audits
because of these you saw there was the
you see the colorado woman
she was like we're banning frauds yeah
yeah that was funny because i was like
colorado no one asked you like you're
not one of the states
so i liken it to like you're sitting in
a meeting and someone just goes i didn't
fart
and then you're like no one said
anything dude
but are we in for a surprise in the next
few minutes all right a few seconds
people are gonna take a notice
and then it's like if someone just
randomly blurted that out you'd be like
uh where'd that come from did you fart
like why did you say that
so that's you know she blurts it out but
um but anyway in in reference to uh
you're talking about a level of courage
that the vast majority of people don't
have
conservatives anti-establishment the
right regular people
well then the left is full of not
regular people
no it takes no courage to follow
the current that has been
cut for you by
the leaders in culture then it should
take no courage for someone who opposes
this to just ride the wave and say
that's racist
don't say it again i'm writing it down
do you think
that this this hr let me tell you this
you've got an hr director
middle-aged white woman and she's given
a brochure about diversity in
initiatives and then you start huffing
and puffing about how she's saying
racist things
do you think this woman's going to you
think she's going to keep going risk her
job
or do you think she's going to be like i
don't know are you white or black
it doesn't matter oh yes it does i don't
think it does oh wait
the people leading the charge like rob
and d'angelo are white and they're the
ones coming up making the demands and
they're getting their way
are they yes yeah that she's getting
paid tens of thousands of dollars to
teach at universities
and her applied critical race theory is
appearing in schools across the country
right she's getting it she's getting
everything she wants no no but
to protest against her
you can't be white no no no no no no no
no
you can grift and here it is used
properly
you can grift from this
this you know system this ecosystem
of grievance and fiction and whatever it
is
and be white but you can't push back
against it and be white so hold on let
me break this down
if a white person like robin deangelo
says
this system is it is racist she's
allowed to do it
and then if you say literally the same
thing you can't
if you're white i'm not sure i follow if
i say literally the same thing
i i can say it but it's the next thing
that i say that you're talking about
no no so like you're you're in a
diversity meeting
and you have a white woman speaking at
your hr meeting and you accuse her of
being racist
try it on me try okay so you just said
to me your your little
magic formula you think is gonna solve
this problem
mr coleman i don't understand why you're
allowed to talk about
about white privilege that makes it
sound like it's better to be white no
i didn't say to say that say say why are
you having us having a meeting center on
white people
why are white people because white
people are the problem
so why people are dominating white
people have dominated the cultural and
historical so
are you a white supremacist on the
contrary
i'm going to report you to the eeoc if
you say one more word you bigot
i am not gonna sit here and listen to
you talk about your white supremacist
views in front of me
and after everything my family's been
through say it one more time and i will
go to your boss
sir say it one more time you white
supremacist
the mere fact that i'm writing it down
the words white supremacist
and then you go to the eeoc and here's
what you say
okay so you're we're now going to just
do like on a tv show and just show the
next scene
after the extremely unlikely stuff
happens
fade to the next okay i i think you you
misunderstand that uh i'm saying
you think that see you what you
demonstrated was
nothing but courage you demonstrated
that you're willing to
being tim pool and having a lot of
confidence and having a certain station
in life
and being a guy with certain amount of
testosterone that you're prepared
to really push this and to try to
intimidate
a midwit a professional midwit
most people won't do that perhaps i've
done it and i have one on multiple
occasions you're tim poole
so when i when i was making 10 bucks an
hour
working for political uh fundraising
organizations
i uh or i should say when i did
fundraising i've sued two organizations
and one doing exactly as i've described
that's why you're timpool today perhaps
so if people just use the system as it
existed they'd start winning
the problem people like you but most
people aren't like you take it from me
because i'm more like you than i'm like
the other people
the left is doing this does the left
have more courageous people than the
right
no then why do they keep doing it why
are they the ones to file eeoc
complaints and win
because the eeoc is owned by them
because the press is owned by them
because the courts are owned by them
because the academia is owned by them
they had a system in place
especially in academia and in the
corporate world it turns out to everyone
surprised noah was ready for this
and as well as the attorneys general
they worked their way
very very brilliantly into a number of
very
very important institutions in american
life
the academia project goes back already
before even before i was born
but the fruit of that has been
that in all the sectors where ideas
are filtered for acceptability
the left owns them let me ask you
something
if if somebody's not going to let you
ask me something if somebody went to the
eeoc and said
my hr director made a bunch of racist
comments and i asked them to stop and
they refused what do you think the eeoc
would say what were the comments
i'm i'm not going to repeat them i mean
it was disparaging things about race
they were talking about how races are
better than others
mr poole please when you have a chance
when you cool down a little bit
write down the comments for us because
we can't proceed unless we have a
detailed explanation of what was
made and also give us the names of
everyone else who was at the meeting
well it was to describe what that what
these comments were
and we will then send it over to the
very big warehouse over there where they
keep the ark of the covenant
and we'll get back to you as soon as
possible so
so let me let me ask you why why is it
that when i went to these agencies
on more than one on two occasions and
did exactly
as i described it worked because you've
got
balls i don't know that's that's
irrelevant i'm talking about when was it
when was it
this was 13 years ago
13 and 14 years ago 4013 years ago
so much has changed in the last 13 years
tim
so much has changed it is mind-boggling
you're advocating for people to not use
the legal
no system as it stands no make an
attempt
far be it for me to do that i'm i'm a
schmuck
who like you keeps knocking his head
against the wall expecting a different
result
i'm all in favor of that so then we
shouldn't but you're asking the
you're asking the empirical question is
why isn't everyone doing it because
there aren't so many schmucks like
coleman and poole
here's the question why is the left
doing it
i rewind academia
courts that's not answering the question
i say it is answering the question
so leftists know that because they
inherently control all the institutions
they can file a complaint and win and
because conservatives are demoralized
they won't even try
yeah okay now now that we've recognized
that conservatives should say oh okay
i'll go out and try
yeah problem solved there you go
ron and tim you've done it thanks for
coming so
when i went to uh these meetings they
didn't ask me for a verbatim
recollection of what happened because
that's impossible to produce
i said to the best of my understanding
they made comments about this that or
otherwise
and that won't happen now it won't
happen now
companies have changed not in 13 years
not in three years in two years
a close family member of mine worked in
microsoft
and said you know as big corporations go
they have their kind of mandatory
mealy mouth mouthing you know stuff
about diversity but it's pretty
cool i got a feeling things are really
done here
in the last two years it turned
into a nightmare in the last two
years corporate america is cowed
the the judiciary is counted things
things have changed a great deal but
i'll tell you something else tim
this is a related phenomenon
i had to leave two law firms in a row
because i was taking on cases
where my partner said well you're
representing
a side that has a really bad reputation
gavin mcinnes
or gab they're associated with nazis
no no i'm taking on those cases because
they're being wrongly associated with
nazis
i'm trying to vindicate their
reputations
yeah but you know we have we have
interns
and we have vendors and we have clients
some of them are holocaust survivors
some of them
are um you know uh
you know we give money to the to this uh
you know uh
affirmative action program we just can't
and you know i understand if you've got
a law firm that you've built up over 50
or 100 years
and you're an equity partner in that
organization and
you have a stake in it and ron coleman
wants to sweep in
and be the guy who's gonna
show the world that gavin mcinnes isn't
isn't a racist or an extremist or show
the world that gab
is entitled to sue google because they
are monopolist
it's not well maybe ron you might want
to do that you might even be right but
it's working very well for the rest of
us to not do that
and we can do without your revenue like
you we like what you're practicing
thank god i'm with harmy dylan now and
she takes on not the craziest cases but
relatively crazy cases
because they're not so crazy that's so
that's the
the analog to what we're talking about
here is is that it's an uphill
battle but yes we have to do it we have
to do it
so i'm curious like this these firms you
describe
you know they're very worried about the
threats or accusations
couldn't anyone of any political
persuasion just weaponize that by
claiming i'm gonna accuse you of it what
are you gonna do about it
i mean you don't say it like that
obviously but what if one of these
interns was
you know a far right and they were like
you know what i'm sick of it
my pronouns are flabberdooflabidi
don't use my pronouns and i'll file i
mean in new york for instance it's a
human rights violation with a fine of up
to 250 000
for willful misuse of someone's pronouns
right that's unconstitutional and
eventually that that will be
that will be thrown out on first
amendment grounds but it'll need
challenging and which means it'll need a
legal case
also someone will have to attempt it
against a company right who will have to
then defend themselves
i'll do you one better when we were
involved in these coveted lockdown cases
harmeet and i
we would identify a location where there
was something for example
these rockland county cases we had
trouble
finding people who would who would allow
their names to be used
as plaintiffs we had funding for these
cases they weren't going
out of pocket they weren't going to
spend any money
we just need you to be the complainant
can someone else do it i want my rights
vindicated but i want someone else to
vindicate them for me
that's the problem that's true yeah yep
in that case freedom deserves to lose
but since we won't let it we'll keep
knocking our heads against the wall
you have to fight the good fight we have
a concept in jewish ethics
that you're not obligated to complete
the work but neither are you free to
desist from it
and as long as we're here and we are
here
and we have our faculties and we have
our
testosterone and our beanies
several big ones and little ones
[Laughter]
we gotta fight we gotta fight and that
means we're gonna make less money than
the people who
are taking the easier road and and we're
gonna
be called nazis and we're gonna have you
know
get postcards with swastikas on them and
crossed out swastikas like i got
when the gavin case was in the news
that's just the price of
allowing meaning and
a sense of mission
becloud your better judgment for comfort
and wealth there's an exploitation of
capitalism a lot of ways
the willingness for big corporations to
be subverted for the right price china
exploits it to a great deal well i will
tell you that i
am so you know i mentioned before that i
used to do a lot of trademark work and
in fact for many years
uh i'm just not doing it anymore because
i think blogging doesn't really matter
i'm almost less interested in the topic
but i had a trademark blog called
likelihood of confusion at likelihood of
confusion.com
that was considered to be a you know a
pretty
important opinion
resource and one of the things i notice
so i'm very interested in branding and
marketing and i have been astonished
at the process of co-option
by radical movements by marketing
companies
and i remain convinced and someone told
me there's a really good book about this
and i forgot who wrote it
about how this happened but i am
convinced
that in the long term it is
because i'm an economics major perhaps
this cannot last i wish i remember maybe
was it you
who somebody what was it you someone
tweeted
a picture of a bunch of models that was
me
it was you the victoria's secret thing
not girls you want to marry necessarily
okay
we're now because we're not going to use
beautiful girls anymore we're
okay you signaled your virtue now sell
some panties
okay ladies
want to see pretty ladies
in the things they want to buy because
they want to see themselves as the
pretty ladies
exactly and no matter how you can't j
so you can't the market will not lie
and this is like the grandest challenge
to
the american way of life
of all the things we've spoken about the
idea that an advertisement will try to
convince you
that the fantasy world that madison
avenue has sold us
since you know world war ii
should not be the fantasy life of
comfort and good looks
but should be the word the fantasy life
of obesity
disgustingness slovenliness and i think
it ain't gonna work
well i'll push back a little bit i will
say get go broke not a
law um but does have its tendencies
there are some things that get woke and
do well uh as much as captain marvel got
flack from a lot of people the film
it made i think a billion dollars so
they just say okay well we'll try and do
better next time but we'll still push a
lot of the same stuff
now when it comes to uh victoria's
secret the dove real beauty campaign
happened a long time ago
they still push forward on it and i
think what people need to understand
about this is yeah women want to see
themselves as the pretty lady right
but what happens when the average uh
body mass index is on the rise in the
united states and many of these women
are
are chowing down in a pint of ben and
jerry's every night oh no you got it
backwards buddy
i want to think that even though i can't
fit into my wedding dress
that if i buy that how do you say shimmy
c-h-e-m if i buy
i'll look that way i'll look close
enough to that
does coleman get it i'll look close
enough to that that my husband
will turn off the tv next
friday night right maybe but there's got
to be a limit
i mean at a certain point someone who's
let's give more abundally obese knows
they're not going to look that way
so they have to justify it by saying
you're fat phobic and then demanding
body positive models which they do
they're fooling no one and let me tell
you something else there's a lot of that
lying going on and it's to me that's one
of the reasons
this will fall apart
i i'm so comfortable with homosexuality
with gay people
my two friends kevin and bruce got
married and they were
making out under the under the uh you
know the canopy and it was so beautiful
you're lying you were nauseated
you were nauseated not because you're
against homosexuals not because you want
to go into their bedrooms not because
you want to arrest them
because you're a heterosexual person and
you don't like to see men kissing
you just don't dare admit it and in fact
you'll go so far to
claim that you're cool with it that
you'll lie about it
but when the men get together
and the women get together and they
think they're safe what do they say
about something that they think is
uncool or creepy
it's so gay yeah but that's that's
that's just like uh uh
a grunt at this point saying saying
things instinctively they don't
have any meaning other than some kind of
negative connotation but
i disagree on that thing and there's a
lot of people that don't care
i think there the number of people who
don't care is
far far smaller than you think it is
unless you're one of those guys in which
case you can tell me
that you're cool with it i have a hard
time believing it
i think and by the way
again i couldn't care less if they do it
but
i mean our references in this area are
so
f are so off the chart that we don't
even know
where the center is anymore let me ask
you if you ever see the movie mask
the guy with the crazy face no i i don't
really see a lot of movies
no not the masks i don't know there's a
movie mask where a guy's
face is like y'all crazy uh
there's a there's an old uh mad magazine
trope
about uh um you remember mad max oh of
course
public displays of affection and one of
them was
it was uh two fat people kissing
and holding hands and everyone's
standing around all like frowning and
grumpy
and the next one was two beautiful
people kissing and everyone's going oh
and they're both male and female there's
just the point being made about people
not being
like happy with things they don't find
attractive i suppose right but that
could be heterosexual
in this case as well like two ugly
people kissing would
you know or or uh i suppose another
example in a similar vein is this meme
that goes around where it's like an
attractive guy
like say hey you're looking good susan
and she's like oh yeah and then it's a
fat guy saying looking good she's like
help help i'm being oppressed you know
so i i think there's a point you're
making
i push back a little bit i genuinely
believe there's a lot of people who
literally don't care and don't feel
anything
and there's probably a lot of people
that actually think like oh that's so
sweet if they see two men or two women
you know what i mean i think you're
right i think there's a lot of people
but i do agree with there's probably a
lot of people too that's probably the
distinction between
in some ways the left and the right
there are many people who are very much
more traditional and much more
i think that's by the way well listen
one thing the right
has come to terms with and include
myself here
to the extent i can given the community
that i live in and my own
religious beliefs which is not limitless
not a limitless extent we simply
can't have the attitude towards
homosexuality
that we had during the reagan years it's
that door is
closed richard grinnell has to be a cool
guy we have to
we we can't we simply can't
ha live in a world where we're gonna say
he can't be a leader or a potential
president
where we might have done that when i was
in high school i think
a lot of the the uh issues with
say let's say like a movie where you've
got like a gay couple be it men
men or women i think the issue is
actually political and people are more
angry about the politics being forced
into it as opposed to
any real issue with like homosexuality
because i i
i these are the comments you see online
when it's like there's a movie and you
have like the main characters you know
in a lesbian relationship the comments
aren't like ah you know she's a lesbian
no it's like they're
putting politics that doesn't need to be
in the movie in the movie
but i don't know i don't know you know
how about we take super chats and see
what the audience knows
we don't know i can't read mine so i
don't know people think or feel you know
what i mean
and i think a lot of us project our
world view i mean fact this is a fact
i'm pretty sure that we project our
emotions and feelings into other people
and assume they feel the same way
narrator tim
is accusing ron of projecting i'm using
everybody
everyone ron looks on in anguish but the
reality is
so uh there's this uh uh there's this
nbc reporter who just like
is one of the worst fake news reporters
and i did a uh ground.news it's a great
website
blind spot search oh yeah you ever see
this no you can track
the the bias of the individual based on
uh necessarily the bias but like the new
stories they interact with
this is a guy who supposedly writes
about the right
but 84 of his interactions are with
left-wing news sources
not even centrists like you know the ap
or reuters or whatever which are
considered interest
like literal left-wing slate stuff and
this guy's writing articles claiming to
be like an expert on their
sure sure sure that's that's that's just
absurdity but
there's been several studies done that
show liberals get about 95
of their news from left-wing news
sources and about five from conservative
moderates get two-thirds from liberal
and one-third from conservative and
conservatives are inverted
two-thirds from conservative sources
one-third from liberal showing moderates
and conservatives are actually to a
certain degree
reading each other's sources to better
understand a fuller view what's
happening
and liberals just believe whatever cnn
tells them
but let's see let's let's see what the
uh audience believes what is tell of
them
so uh if you haven't already smash that
like button subscribe to this channel
and share the show if you really like it
we'll have a bonus segment coming up at
11 so make sure you go to timcast.com
become a member
let's read uh some of these super chats
name
surname says hey tim what are some good
sources about bitcoin i can show my
normie friends and parents
i like max keiser but he's a bit too bit
too gnar nars for my boomer parents
um any any any
any bitcoin knowledge well was it where
what could you show someone that's like
not gonna
pop like papiano what's narnia's though
max is like a cartoon character he's
amazing
but he shows up here with sunglasses and
money guns and he's firing
life yeah so this is this is this is
this is
this others it turns out that this is
like um
um what you will call it like you just
told me it wasn't like okay nevermind
it's a good question who's like a good
authoritative serious believable
source of bitcoin knowledge these days
i'm at a loss
not sure are there any are you big into
crypto ron
not at all i'm a big fan i wish i could
answer your question
anthony pompliano yeah yeah that's
awesome yeah that's what lydia was
saying
check him out he's like uh a good
regular just like yeah good podcast got
his own podcast yeah
all right all right let's see i'll sign
on for that ulysses says tim can you
explain the michael malus troll on the
reuben report
for us less savvy viewers can you at
least make a subscriber segment on it
um i'll i will say only a little bit
are you familiar with the superhero
called the question
is that a question
investigative journalist character he
has no face
like it's just nothing there and he's
like a conspiracy theorist kind of guy
so michael malus dressed up in a costume
of this character and appeared on
dave rubin's show and that's the troll
it was good he was also wearing a star
of david
to imply that he was jewish yeah
superhero caught the question that the
question was jewish that's right
moving on about the explaining miles
kinslow says
hey guys tim there is a woman named
gabrielle clark who is currently
fighting critical race theory with a
landmark case please hear her story
stop state-sponsored racism stop crt
i really don't like people saying
critical race theory
i think it is a leftist it is a trap the
left is good with this stuff and they've
won
chris ruffo's fantastic he's brilliant
he's targeting the stuff
and he's standing on their battlefield
and it's helping them tremendously
unfortunately interesting yeah i i've
heard
i've heard a few other people making
that point about about chris
so when you hear that schools are
teaching critical race theory
what's being implied is they're applying
critical race theory to their teachings
it's very different
this means that when they give you a
math problem it'll it's like this was an
actual example i saw it's like
john is stopped by police three times in
a year
but you know kwame is stopped 492 times
what percentage change or blah blah
it's like you know how many what's the
difference and so that's applying
critical race theory into
math so what you hear is that they're
teaching critical race theory well
they're applying critical race theories
ideology
in school programs about diversity
initiatives what happens is
uh with all due respect because chris is
a smart guy and i respect the work he's
doing
the left easily pivots their defense
they look to and when the parents start
saying they're teaching critical race
theory
these journalists and these and these
activists go
name one school that has ever quoted
derek bell
two fifth graders and they're like uh
well they're not
and you said they're teaching critical
race there okay kimberly crenshaw
are they reading candy are they reading
the more minor ones d'angelo
i didn't think so and you thought it was
true and then what happens is you'll get
some 20 year old going
mom can you point to one example where
they mentioned
this you know that or otherwise she's
like no because they're lying to you mom
it's fox news it's lying to you
instead of just saying they're teaching
identitarianism
because then these people are going to
be like what's identitarianism and then
when the activists try to pivot
well i mean it's like white supremacy
it's like oh well identitarianism is
policy based on identity is that what
you're advocating for
yes don't those white people in europe
call them such identitarian well they
are
and you're teaching the same thing yes
and the washington post put out an
article
that advocated for the importance of
white racial identity they did
today so don't say critical race theory
you could say identitarianism
the problem is they're not even teaching
identitarianism they're they're
identitarianly
teaching things so right right right
it's applying
critical race theory into other subjects
so
uh through the land they actually call
it critical praxis
so when the right comes out and says
critical race theory the left easily
goes
name one critical race theorist we've
ever brought up in the school
and of course they don't teach you the
theory of anything it's fifth grade
and you can't so at these board meetings
they're like
mr mr smith it was you're complaining
about crt
can you name one critical race theory
author that you've heard your
your son or daughter uh quote i didn't
think so
next and it's over because these parents
don't know
i went to uh i was shopping in um west
virginia
and i heard parents complaining about
critical race theory
and i said you need to stop saying that
you know like i understand
everything you're talking about they're
not teaching critical race theory
first and foremost what they are
teaching is written in critical theory
in general which includes critical
gender theory
but they're applying the ideology into
the teachings
if you go into these meetings and say
this they're going to in two seconds
shut you down and say you have no idea
what you're talking about
and they win so you can just bypass this
whole argument by saying they are
teaching wokeness
because wokeness is not defined by the
left critical race theory is
the problem with the anti-establishment
be it liberal moderate conservative
those who challenge wokeness
is or the democrats in that and for that
matter is that we all keep standing on
their battlefield the black lives matter
writers mancerectionists
the george floyd and no go zone antifa
autonomous
no go zone the police one it's a no-go
zone criminal no goes on you know who
else does that
tim poole i heard you use the term
capitalism
more than once tonight that is a term
that was
coined by karl marx boom
free enterprise free enterprise
but you're right see i grew up in a
world that had
already succumbed to constantly seeding
the battleground to the left
so you just stop using their terms
critical race theory is their name
that's not what i call it i call it
wokeness and then people are like well
you know whatness is kind of pejorative
good
it's a bad thing it's authoritarian cult
ideology i don't care if
look when you get into the core of
critical race theory they
they'll use some sound ideas to justify
why it's a good theory certain things
like
did christopher columbus actually
discover america and then
some people counter it was actually leaf
eriksen and then they'll counter with
the native americans were already here
and that's the the morsel of truth that
triggers this
oh and then the life starts saying you
see they were just teaching true history
of
of racism blah blah blah so no i'm not i
have no concern for the most part of a
of a school system in any grade teaching
a theory if they want to teach a theory
they would say
there are several authors who believe x
this is what they've said that's fine
the problem is when they create math
problems where it's like
john has been stopped by police three
times and listen
well before wokeness my wife was looking
at my son's
um my my all my sons are
large adults now but when they were much
younger
she was looking at one of one of their
homework assignments and it was
um which of these scores
which of these scores in the basketball
game between i'm sure if jane
is listening this far into this that i
got it wrong but it was
which there were three basketball games
between the two schools
which which score was the least
shows that the game was the least fair
and the answer was of course the score
the the game with with the largest
discrepancy discrepancy between the
score wow fairness has
nothing to do with that whatsoever maybe
only three guys played for this
for the team that scored 37 points more
but this is a this goes to to a
a corrupt a corruption and
a subversive phenomenon that's been
going on within education
which has now been leached onto
by particular political movements which
has worked out just
great for everyone concerned it's a
religion uh
you know crt is one aspect of whatever
this religion is
and it is a non-theistic religion
everything it's a it's a
it's a different moral framework from
judeo-christian values and i think
that's
a big you know one of the big fissures
between the left and the right
so their moral framework is quote there
is no truth but power
and quote and then the other moral
framework which is based on
traditionally judeo-christian values has
a lot more to do
with a lot of at least a search for
truth a search for the truth
that that is greater than power but but
i'll also
i want to clarify this too i'm not
saying that the the
the people who oppose wokeness are all
theistic and believe
and god and all that stuff but their
values they were born with were they
come from a country that was rooted in
those values and this is what was born
of it
their ideology is something entirely new
or lacking any kind of moral framework
all right let's uh center sun says on
friday super chat asked what's left
of alt left and tim suggested an ai
government
it sounded eerily familiar to the
resource-based economy dreamed up by
peter joseph
you should look into him as a potential
guest
i don't know you know so what were
saying was
the far left literal communists think
they're centrists
if that were true what would be to the
left of them right if if the left on the
economic scale
is cooperative which is communism and
the right is competitive which is
free enterprise then what's left of
communism
well the left right
paradigm has always had problems
there's a whole school of of twitter
stupidity that goes like this and you've
seen it a gazillion times
national socialism is really a form of
socialism no no no
no no no no read about national
socialism
it's true that hitler if it's true that
the national socialists
as a party have origins in the
worker-based
socialism that was roiling europe around
you know in the early years of the 20th
century it's true that goebbels
himself was a marxist and
to a large extent remained one he
to the end of his life his wretched
awful evil life
he used paradigms i mean he
used the nomenclature of workers
struggle
he never abandoned that uh party work
and you know these kinds of things that
you see from soviet literature
but national socialism had nothing to do
with the state owning the means of
production
it was not a centralized economy it was
not even a command economy
it has very little to do with socialism
so
the the the whole way of understanding
right and left is very confusing so
i i would assume that when a communist
says no we're
we're this we represent the center that
they themselves must be positing
something to the left
of them right so what what is it well
they they made this chart where it shows
bernie sander
bernie sanders to the left of center and
it says and then
the left of him it says watch this space
and they're like it says reality
like bernie sanders calls himself a
socialist and advocates for worker
ownership of companies
and he's center left all right so pol
pot is to the left of bernie sanders
yeah okay mount zetong is to the left of
bernie sanders and further north
would it too like monarch a monarchy
would be no that's authoritarian
but is it far left authoritarian it's
not even the same
scale i'm a political compass with uh
north south east and west or whatever
left economic is cooperative and right
economic is free enterprise monarchy is
merely who's the head of state
is it is it hereditary you know
in in in um
south korea and north korea the last
three dictators have been father son and
grandson
that is what we used to call a monarchy
but because they call themselves a
republic
oh they must be a republic right just
because if i call myself an
anti-far i must be against fascism
anti-first
yeah we should just call north korea uh
a monarchy
a single authority right no a single
hereditary authority that's what makes a
monarchy
there you go predatory monarchy you
could have a non-hereditary monarchy
i in fact intend to that that's the
future for this country like you vote
they vote like a council of elders to
vote for the next king
after the kingdom well that used to be
way back that's what they used to do in
the german in the
german federation you know what would be
really funny if north korea decided to
implement the um the black panther
wakanda style of um what patriarchal
hereditary uh
rule by combat chosen by comet so
basically the the sons of the elders
have to fight whoever wins
becomes the the king you'd be like by
basketball though
but just frankie goes to hollywood two
tribes
i still haven't seen that movie is it
good is it a movie i don't know is it a
movie frankie
all right all right let's read some more
super chats all right group b
says tim a micro strategy now now owns
one out of
every 210 bitcoins that will ever be
mined who does
micro strategy okay are you familiar
with them i don't know a lot about them
like a business consulting thing or
something
they say uh and hash rate is down
because
china miners are leaving bullish much
oh man when the price of bitcoin goes
down i just like buy
it has been i know it's great it's good
news it's because china plays these
dirty games to manipulate poor people
uh they'll be like we're gonna ban
bitcoin oh
and then the price drops and then rich
people buy up as much as they can from
the panic poor people
you can actually see it in the
transactions
so when elon musk made his tweet that
like we're not gonna you know
sell this is according to some stuff
that i read i could be wrong so fact
check me
but i read a bunch of reports showing
that the bulk of the transactions were
small amounts like 20 to 50 bucks maybe
100 bucks
it was poor people who put in only as
much as they could and when the num when
the price started tanking they panicked
and sold
and the rich people started moving
millions of dollars into bitcoin but
they're substantially fewer dollars from
the wealthy going in and more from the
poor
fleeing so the price was going down the
way i described it was
at the time when bitcoin was at thirty
eight thousand dollars i said if someone
offered you
a million dollars in cash in a case and
all you had to do was write a check for
38 grand would you do it
well of course it makes no sense like
why would i that's how i view bitcoin
when you have all of these massive
companies
hedging their bets and making massive
investments into bitcoin and the people
selling are the poor people
i feel bad for those poor people i want
to warn them but i'm pretty confident
the rich people think they're going to
make bank off bitcoin so that's what i'm
telling anybody else what to do
you know i'm going to do my thing not
financial advice
but in november i bought a bitcoin and i
look at it as a savings account
i'm like okay you know i got some money
i want to you know put it away
i bought a bunch of bitcoin in november
and boy am i happy
been happy the whole time i'm happy too
yeah me too
but only because he's happy yeah it's
different reasons
[Laughter]
i've been meditating a lot
someone's trying to uh michael no
andy wait they're trying to michael
knowles andy no oh
snap so here's what they said die steel
wobble says got my second shot and now
i'm unmasked
just like andy nosebook unmasked inside
antifa's radical plan to destroy
democracy
purchase at amazon barnes and noble
goodreads and you know
you know the thing places uh definitely
pick up michael noll's book uh andy
knows book
pick up michael malus's book um i
actually just did
a a chapter for michael mouse's book
audio chapter it was a reading an
anarchist essay
me too oh excellent great this is gonna
that's gonna be an excellent audiobook
michael's got like the best people
it was epic it was tiring it was time
wow
i had to read one that was french so
but it was translated oh so there were
like certain words and phrases in there
and i'm like
that'll be fun all right ted two says
tim i get your point about military
budget and industry
but a lot of the systems we use are
expensive tech designed to increase our
survivability in the battle space
it's not just it's not all just bombs c
m raps ecm et cetera
oh yeah i agree not only that
why do we invest so much in
survivability because
politically we cannot afford to
trade bodies
for hardware the way other regimes can
it's like uh the zep brannigan strategy
just send wave after wave of your own
man until the kill bots reach their kill
limit and then you win
unfortunately that was like the soviet
strategy you know wave after wave of low
quality but just lots of people
and i worked out for him in a lot of
places all right michael nguyen says hey
tim i know
y'all helped out a cat a little while
back now a friend whose doggo got run
over
is in a very bad way can you shout out
this word doggo to get some help at
gofundme
to find the page look for noah pelvis
surgery by claudia reyes
any little bit helps reyes latino
pronunciation
so uh claudio or claudia claudia
we had someone uh oh sorry latina let's
see next my bad
we had somebody shout out their gofundme
and so i shouted it out and then
i can't believe that you do that that
would strike me as really
really bad podcasting hygiene too
really yeah well now everyone keeps
doing it that's exactly no further
questions
i don't know that's when they step
they're paying for it
they are yeah they're super chats they
give me money and then i really
sound like that i'm like to all the
advertisers out there
you can join the lottery of getting
promo because a lot of people are like
hey shout out my podcast and they'll
like super chat a couple bucks
but the podcast the sponsors get that
guaranteed spot in the beginning
right hey uh i you know i i won't
some of them are in poor taste they'll
be like can you shout out my gofundme
car and i'll be like
look saving someone's dog i want to help
save people's bets you know i mean
that's miserable in other words if you
want a new car call it a dog
that's right but then you're committing
fraud and gofundme will ban you
oh don't do that yeah you can't i'm just
thinking about how you helped that cat
yesterday i was that crossed my mind
yeah i've got to make sure that cat is
taken care of i would be i if if our cat
bucko was was injured and i couldn't
afford to save him i'd be
i'd be thinking like anything i could do
i could sell you know
loyalty right nah cats aren't
particularly loyal yeah i'm
not right i mean you're loyal to the cat
right that is a one-way street you know
i was thinking about i think cats are
pretty fascistic
right cats like you because you're
powerful
if you were small they would torture you
and
they don't care what you're smarter will
the will to power
is what the that's the feline nature
that's right that's right
dogs are loyal loyal soldiers you know
they'll stand in the front line for you
you know the story of uh hajiko right
hachiko dog in japan waited like 10
years
oh yeah outside of a train station they
built a statue for him that's right
that's my uh the dog was like i will not
unless you know i have given my you know
unless they're given confirmation of the
death they will not
abandon my patronus as a dog i took the
harry potter test
yeah apparently i would shoot one out of
a wand if anything yeah
that's kind of uh grounding woot do for
you says you need to look into the
abolish the atf build better it just
transfers the duty to the fbi
and i did call that out on the segment
that i did about marjory taylor green's
bill it does
it abolish it it reverses a lot of the
rules going back to august 2020
but for the most part it just means the
fbi will doing what the f what the atf
does
which can't much can't possibly be
better because the fbi is
i think we all agree the worst
yeah the worst
christopher irvine says australia banned
crt from national curriculum yesterday
god bless senator pauline hanson shout
out to pam
to uh wow did that say pam was to say
parn
pardon wow i'm surprised that happened
in australia
wow i think it says parn p-a-r parne i
don't know
parmesan maybe trying to order something
sean parnell
all right alabama toolbox says tim have
you considered inviting
janmi park onto your show she is a north
korean defector living in the u.s
recently she has spoken out against
world culture oh
have we considered that we have
considered that interesting indeed
all right i wasn't part of that
conversation no you weren't i'm sorry
i'm just saying have you ever been north
korea i'd rather not say
i still haven't it's a secret proud
native says tim i tried to fight and
couldn't get the lawyers lost everything
trying to build up now not everyone is
as lucky as you granted colorado
wouldn't have acted the same
um is that a secret is are our missiles
going to be now launched by based on
those i mean that seems like a series of
non-sequiturs to me yeah it was kind of
like a code
i've been you know speaking english now
for well over the 40 years
that i've been on this planet and um i
don't what the hell does that mean
i don't think it's luck to uh
do things i don't know oh
yeah i understand the illusion that tim
felt that you've fallen into this
place that you're at but i mean it takes
you know 10 12 years of 10 hour days of
work
you know not only work but imagination
and creativity
and not an ounce of luck unfortunately
what is luck it's a big in china like
chinese culture luck is a real thing
that just fortuitous things occur to you
more often but they say
luck favors the prepared fortune favors
the bull black figures are prepared
their ability to seize opportunities
when they arrive or see them whenever
well so
uh intelligence and as much as the left
loves to insult me
my success is largely to the my ability
to predict when big news events were
going to happen based on
prior news so for instance i got to
ferguson within a couple days i said
occupy wall street within a couple days
so when you have 10 news stories that
are occurring around the country
and you can only choose one and only one
of them is going to be the big news
story
if you can't accurately predict which
one is going to be big you'll end up at
the wrong one
i think cernovich is good at that too
yeah so a few examples
occupy wall street there's a bunch of
places i could have been i decided to go
to new york and i was there
within i think the third day of occupy
wall street and i was there for i stayed
in new york afterwards
the ferguson riots there were a bunch of
things going on a better example would
be
the gezi park protests vice and i had
discussed going to the pro
the g8 protests in like northern ireland
or something
at the very last minute i said change my
ticket to istanbul we're going
and they're like are you sure yes yes
yes and it ended up becoming one of
their biggest
pieces they ever did i was broadcasting
to a ridiculous amount of people
live streaming was on all their tvs they
were super excited now
any other person would they have been
able to predict the right place to be
to have known to be fair i was watching
videos of things happening being like we
got to cover this story
it wasn't like i knew that someone was
going to show up and a cop was going to
shoot somebody
it was the news happened i see a bunch
of news across the country i said
this one is going to be the biggest
story and here's why get me a plane
ticket right now in fact
vice would not buy me the ticket to
ferguson they told me to wait and i said
no and i bought the ticket myself
and if i had not gone they would have
not gotten that coverage and it was
like the biggest thing vice had ever
ever done when i went to ferguson it was
like 70 000 concurrent viewers
which is not the biggest i've done but
at the point you know several years ago
it was it was ridiculous
for a live stream to have that level of
viewership particularly with mobile
and they told me no when i when i said
it at first bought myself the ticket and
flew there and then they were like bravo
and then i quit because of it but so so
that's that's that's it it's not luck
it's um there are a lot of people
who used to cover field and do field
reporting from these different places
and they'd be in they'd be in the place
that wasn't the biggest story so
you can call it luck and call whatever
you want but it was pretty fortuitous
that i was in all of these huge
you know but isn't it usually the
producer like in a typical news
organization the producer
sends the field reporter you had an
entrepreneurial
role in choosing from where you would do
your reporting
yeah because usually you know typical
reporters
you know the producer says here's your
ticket to
ireland northern ireland there there are
some places i've gone where it ended up
being the wrong place
but i had a tendency to be in the right
place at the right time
yeah and also sees when you are in the
right place at the right time to be able
to turn it into something big
otherwise maybe well that was another
thing too during occupy wall street the
the initial live streaming was being
done via laptop with webcams they were
holding up
and they would just point at random
things when i started live streaming i
would
use my phone with ustream which was like
the new mobile app and i would narrate
explaining what was going on what i was
seeing while answering questions and no
one had done that for the most part
so people were given an option watch a
stream where they're just pointing a
camera and moving back and forth or
here's a guy talking to me and answering
my questions
i mean what what were the you weren't
even on
did you even have 3g yeah it was it was
uh it was uh uh
it was in the wymax era so 3g and
i think ymax was what i was using 1
megabit up and down
amazing isn't it really really bad
uh connection dan ian says did tim just
admit to accusing someone of a racially
based crime using theatrics for profit
wtf uh
no i said that if you are in a racist
meeting to accuse the boss of being
racist because they are being racist and
violating the civil rights act
i'm literally saying if you are in a
workplace meeting and they break the law
to tell them to warn them not to and
then to go to the proper administration
when they do
simple as that he did say that uh you
might not win
but when someone comes out and says
white people are inherently xy or
otherwise yeah that's literally racial
discrimination like
you you have to file complaints about
that stuff the left is doing it
all right let's see we'll read a couple
more here ian hall says
ron you need to come pocket format it's
instant chutzpah
plus added feature have you met my
lawyer he is jewish all hr departments
do you get that i don't i don't know
what the hell is awesome
all right eddie says hey tim currently
working for cnn as a software engineer
contractor which is funny considering my
views
but it pays the bills and this super
chat well that's cool
but can you look into one timothy 4 3
seems it speaks on leftists who hold
views like vegans and feminists
interesting working for cnn huh
now that's a topic i wish you would have
had time to discuss before we started
the super chatting which is you got to
work for cnn that's the job
boycotts boycotts don't buy from amazon
really it's pouring out it's 30 degrees
they can get me the michael malus book
by tomorrow
at 11 o'clock you want me to get in my
car
drive over here where you're in the
middle of nowhere right
yeah drive out to you know huppetsville
to see if maybe the barnes and noble is
open maybe they have the
boycotts man tough question
some some disney plus nickelodeon
nickelodeon yeah coco yeah coca-cola
although i i think someone bought much
equipment it's fine i didn't buy it she
bought it
once i can't taste it anymore and yet i
still drink it that's an addict
we we get these because the coffees
cane sugar sodas that we get we get a
bunch of them and we don't
get a hypertext corn up out of there
yeah i'm a big fan of carrots
you guys every carrots i've i've i have
eaten carrots before
if they're sweet you know you have the
right amount of sugar in your body if
the carrots are sweet yeah that's true
if you're tasty
it's got a lot of sugar in it yeah
carrots be good you're dead to me no no
we're just getting to know each other
it's just beginning that's
that it's just getting started the
traction
all right we'll just read a couple more
here that's like the other ron
in in parks and recreation that's what i
thought you were i was like
ron swanson all right callum excuse me
that's my paper that's my
spirit you're the real ron swanson
kalamaskew says tim
2021 grad here we were taught direct crt
through
reading a tanahisi coates works some guy
who wrote red skull peterson same guy
that's right
he he is in fact the guy who did that
but wait a minute was that in high
school
or was it in college he just has 20 21
grad grad of what
i don't know where all right harley
chuck says tim why do you push home
ownership
homo what home ownership oh i thought we
were going back to the okay
um i push i i won't advise people to buy
homes
i don't give a financial advice or
anything like that but i would say
home ownership is a vehicle by which the
middle class transfer wealth to their
children
and make their lives better and store
their wealth beyond their life to their
descendants
and if you own a home you're likely
going to pay less per month than you
would on rent
granted you have taxes and insurance
it's still less
because the people who own the home and
rent it out have to cover the same thing
so they'll charge a premium
now let's say you buy a house and you're
like i hate taking care of this house
maintenance jeez i wish i had a landlord
i could call it fix it for me
i don't even want to live here anymore i
moved to new york now i regret it now i
own this property oh what am i going to
do
you're going to call a rental management
company who will
take over you'll sign a contract with
them and then you will never think about
it again
and money will just appear in your bank
account passive income
but for some reason all these news
outlets are saying millennials hate
owning homes don't buy homes millennial
you'll hate it
okay whatever i guess more homes for me
millennials don't know how to use
a screwdriver that could be part of the
problem
yeah well uh you're you're a boomer
aren't you
technically didn't the boomers create
the millennials and then the silent
created the gen xers
so i'm the thing is i'm not really a
boomer
63 okay by the time i was of age
the real boomers had completely
cleaned the place they had cleaned
out everything generation
x we were left with disco okay
all right it's pretty awesome i don't
know generation x i think you're a
boomer right
i think they they say now up till 64.
you're about 64 to 79.
it's the it's the they're like a baby
baby boomer yeah or 65
well so listen the baby boomers had the
millennials and
still their values in the millennials
and i think they made a lot of mistakes
as they ten as every generation tends to
well the greatest generation had the
baby brewers
that's right and they were not so great
that's right they were great at storming
the beach
but they turned out the most rotten
generation in american history that's
your hippies
that's right and that's where you get
your uh
you know i love the idea that it was the
hippies who are now
the people extracting the wealth and
holding the properties
and wagging the finger at millennials
the hippies were phonies from
go yeah they did too many drugs that's
what i've heard about some great hippies
if you haven't already smash that like
button and subscribe to this channel
share the show with your friends and you
can follow us on facebook at tim cast
irl as well as instagram where you can
share and like our videos to help
leverage that so we can make everybody
go to timcast.com
where we will have a bonus segment
coming up at about 11 p.m so don't
forget to sign up at timcast.com
support our fearless and fierce
journalism
which is still for the most part yet to
come we've got cassandra fairbanks
leading the show she's doing a lot of
our general articles to start
we are just signing on now our mysteries
and investigative unexplored unexplained
uh writer and editor and then we're
gonna be adding a journalist as well as
a video editor we're gonna be doing more
podcasts
we're gonna be contracting field
reporters to go on the ground so this is
where pitches at teamcast.com becomes
important
because in about a week the alpha
version of our site will be up testing
and then hopefully within a week after
that we will have the functioning site
up but
maybe there's bugs we're also going to
be having a big kickoff
auction of a limited edition pair of
shoes which is
something i'm super excited about we
have tim cast color vans i put on
instagram you can see what they look
like nice
yep that's right so make sure you go to
guest.com sign up what are camera cast
colors
uh like gray and blue all right yeah
exactly
you see what i'm wearing you know so uh
and you look at the walls and everything
so that's
that's what we have and they're like
really nice there's like the leather
inside so they slide on really easily
but the outside is suede so they're
durable yeah i don't screw around
um but but make sure you you uh follow
me personally at tim cast the show is
live monday through friday at 8 pm so
we'll be back tomorrow of course ron do
you want to shout out
uh your show your twitter your twitter
at ron coleman like it's sound spell
like it sounds
okay with an e after the l
the main thing is that also i have a new
a new podcast i've had some i've had
some pretty cool guests
he said no because he says he sucks at
being a podcast guest
and i believe him now that i've heard
him i thought i said
maybe i'll figure out when we have time
i'll take it
coleman nation it's the play on words
love it look for it it's on all the
things and it's taken off like
crazy crazy i mean if you like the
jewish lawyer thing you know
you know we didn't talk too much about
theology i don't know if you ever get
into talking about that
but i i do i'd love to break down the
character of moses someday
break down the characters moses is
moses is quite a boss you know we're
talking about right dude
he was pretty powerful red dude thought
he was a slave and then freed all the
slaves
i saw that movie with christian bale
okay
and that was i'm told that is like a
perfectly uh
adapted version of of moses unlikely
well hey you guys can follow me in
crossland.net and uh at ian crossland
all across social media
keep it real and you guys i think that
you should follow me at sourpatchlids on
twitter because this is something i've
never done before i wanted to reference
a tweet that i made
yesterday this weekend i was thinking
about rules that the right wing needs to
follow
i made a list of about 10 or 11 rules
and one of them is we must choose not to
bigger with each other over petty
disagreements and we literally have oh
sorry about that one
it says we have to sacrifice some of our
individuality to accomplish goals that
give people freedom it is not optional
and i feel like this is really going to
sit hard
with a right wing but i think it's
absolutely necessary you guys should go
read all my rules and tell me what you
think of them
at sourpatchlids on twitter i'm going to
do that as soon as we're done
we are going to see you all in the bonus
segment over at timcast.com so stay
tuned we'll see you all there
you